[Music]
new tonight in North Las Vegas a group
of graduates are celebrating sobriety I
am possible is a substance abuse
recovery program for previous offenders
who are looking to start a new path one
graduate we spoke to says his daughter
was just a month old before he had to
leave and now his family is his
motivation
also now she's four or five so he's
crazy
seeing them go with Donald Marine being
there so it's a big change you know this
program has helped me a lot how to work
myself out self-control anger management
all that stuff they also have the
opportunity to give words of
encouragement to our next class each
class kind of helps to grow the next one
so the culmination of this class here is
a result of all the classes that came
before them
a lot of hard work to get here you can
see a lot of smiles on the faces of
these graduates as they head on to
bigger and better things Williams is
hopeful that his model of Correction is
applied to a larger scale moving forward